cheers to your wedding 2020 we need to
knee
wait what's up I have super spill for
you what yeah one moment you've
questions for me I have questions for
you it's time for roses and rosy with
Raven gates everybody when Lauren Zima
nobody's ever introduced me back to ya
wow this is roses and rose a sip or
spill I am going to ask you some
questions about your time in bachelor
nation your life now you can either
spill answer the question or sip tea I'm
gonna try to spill but I like to sip so
maybe I'll sip and spill alright first
we are going back to the mansion some go
back west okay a sip or spill what is
one thing you really wish you could take
back or do differently ooh
in the mansion from your time on the
shows I really wouldn't take back
anything I mean I think my parents would
want me to take back mount orgasm thing
Nicki's really good at what he does oh
I'm pretty satisfied today but I thought
it was funny and hilarious I'm like
whatever you know cheers to that
you know what Raven a follow up yes sip
or spill didn't make vile really give
you your first orgasm now I think
everyone knows that at this point isn't
like no he didn't on the record it was
just fun and it was funny and I thought
it was hilarious in first bill how far
did you go with Nick smile
not that far like if we were doing bases
I did not do a home run okay you know we
should drink to that anyway every girl
wants great things fireworks magic to
happen zip or spill
do you enjoy things with the man you're
gonna marry Adam
Lauren yes God blessed me he really did
in every facet of the imagination wow
this was supposed to be back to the
mansion but we're taking a turn and I'm
just gonna go with it yeah sip or spill
what does that him do that turns you on
the most it depends on the mood okay but
he's he comes home from work and he has
a suit on and he's making phone calls he
has that big energy you know yeah he's a
businessman yeah you guys have such a
business power couple I just want
everyone to know she just took a coding
ID they graduate from SMU because you
just want to take your stuff to the next
level thanks I try I'm the closeted nerd
you know I really am who do you see in
touch with most now Oh Alexis cuz she
lives in Dallas and we talk every single
day definitely Alexis
not yet but I think 2020 is her year and
I've been trying to prep her about it
I'm like you know we got this were you
super surprised when Adam proposed yeah
I was I was surprised but we had talked
about it before I even moved to Dallas
it was like this is my intention is to
get engaged so of course it's gonna
happen but yes so it's so surprised and
he did something at me much this time I
know I need to clean my ring to your
knowledge who has hooked up with the
most people in bachelor oh we all know
this Blake secret behind the scenes
answer no it's Blake who in bachelor
nation is currently fighting with the
most other people you know what that's
leading into drama check in with Raven
Raven you are getting married soon will
Rachel Lindsay get an invite No why not
because she doesn't like me
I don't want people at my wedding I
don't like me what really happened there
everyone's gonna think I'm totally
bullcrapping this but this is the truth
I don't know
exactly and last time I reached out to
her after this crazy storm of social
media crab came my way
after some things she said what did she
do - cause you're falling out I can't
say I probably say but it was enough for
me to not want to be friends with her
anymore
and you're still not friends with her no
I tried to reach out to her to either
squash it or to like figure out what the
problem was to fix it she didn't want to
talk to me
so I've I've supported her from the
beginning I support her now we're just
closing the chapter okay and that's all
I can do at this point you know because
you feel in your end you tried
everything yeah I feel like I've done
everything I know to do and like I just
I'm so confused about it all like I've
I've lost sleep over it I don't know I
have and I don't think I ever will know
and that's fine with me
I'm just like I'm never gonna hate on
her and I'm not gonna give that reaction
so like I wish her the best I've always
supported her and I don't know what else
is that way so you've asked her and
you've just not gotten an answer
yeah I don't have a clue as like I don't
know if there's like other situations
she's mad at that I'm just not aware of
she won't talk to me about it so it's
just like okay she's made up her mind
and like I have to make up my mind to
like I can't be friends with someone who
like doesn't like me like it's just like
it's simple as that is there anything at
this point that could happen for you two
to reconcile and and are you open to
that um I would never say never I mean
I've loved I've loved her I've had a
very very deep love for her we would
have to have a conversation and we're
not even having that I've mourned the
loss of her friendship I'm over that now
but like I will not argue with her in
the media and I will not talk bad about
her I'm not going to do that so I know
everyone's really like oh she
did something and Rachel said she knows
what she did I don't know what I did I
don't know what else to say let's do a
check-in on something that's not so
dramatic but is more emphatic on your
real life your relationship I knew would
happen at some point or even five years
everything's great just keep going and
we're back okay
let me put myself a new glass wow I knew
[Music]
you and Adam have moved in together
yeah you're buying a house building
house flipping house what's happening
yeah we have a condo okay
and then we bought another house and
we're flipping the house but we're gonna
live in a house but anyone what's about
condo what's he like oh my gosh Laura I
just wish people understood who Adam is
because he's a doer I love him so much
because we're so different that loves us
but you're such a do or two you own your
own business you're you you said he's
very type A Okay and I'm just like go
with the flow so who's going to be more
into your wedding planning Adam has
specific requests for the wedding like
he would like drink Waze and music Waze
which check check we got that done but
he's leaving it to me but I'm really
like oh let's just go low really yeah
and he's cool with that - he's like
let's do it but you guys know you said
are you having it you're doing it yeah
we're doing it at temple Emmanuel in
doubt it's in Dallas okay okay yeah
interfaith wedding all that stuff yeah
and do you have the wedding date
yes May 30th 2020 sip or spill do you
guys know how many kids you want to ask
yeah we're taught definitely two maybe
more we'll see how we handle two big
wedding or small I started out small
it's probably gonna give it
it's not gonna be televised right yeah
whoo and bachelor nation is definitely
getting an invite yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
so she's she's so with that boo no oh
maybe she'll be on paradise or something
cheers to that cheers to your wedding
2020 we need to me
wait what I have super spill for you
what yeah one moment
Raven oh my god this is the first Oh for
more because you have questions for me I
have questions for you oh my god no
one's ever done this before okay
oh the tables have turned Raven gay
listen everyone wants to know about your
relationship with Chris oh the first
question I have has Chris ever given you
roses yes many times
who flirted with who first Oh
hmm I think he flirted with me first a
little bit in an interview because he
like found out I was single for the
first time and I sensed a different
energy from him yeah I kind of read that
energy did he give you like a he gave me
like he was like he was like looking at
my interview cards you barely have
anything written now I have tons of
important we have like 10 words and then
I flirted right back with him the next
time I saw him and then I and then I DM
Tim on Twitter I love it it was coming
up and I said it was so good to see you
the other day happy birthday because I
just felt you know what that's a pretty
neutral thing to say that sure a door
for him and if he wants to walk through
that's great he can walk through and
it's not all I did was say happy
birthday a very casual thing to say I
love it I'm a big fan of women making
the first man oh me too and Adam says
that TV is like I love it when girls
make the first move it's a Power Move
yeah you know okay do you and Chris
drink rose' together and watch The
Bachelor so we actually never drink rosy
together because I drink Rosie's so much
we drink a lot of red wine together and
we don't watch the show together I think
we both do it so much in our work lives
you got it we got to have affirmation so
like what do you watch at home we watch
a lot of rom-coms which is really funny
but like yeah yeah and loves rom-coms
yeah and you have a drink yet that's
good you know what you overdo your so
let's just finish this there's a Louie
why over because I don't wanted to drink
in Loring huh drinking with Lauren is
has Chris ever picked you up in a limo
no but he has flown me in a helicopter
that was a thing where I've always said
to myself to me the dream gift would be
if someone didn't try to predict what
you might want but wanted to make you
happy so it would take you somewhere and
say like just get what you want to get
exactly what he did if he didn't even
know that was my dream chill bumps I
love that so I just love that you're so
happy and I love that he he's so happy
too let's cry oh I thought yep else okay
yeah but you have to do it because
you're gonna yeah she over here Wow
Rayven gates you just turned the tables
on me we broke a glass so good glass we
chugged Rose a yes we talked about our
happiness I flipped it on you
I'm so happy for you oh my gosh alright
by the way tell people where they can go
to get your amazing clothing Oh
everything you do yeah um you can go to
shop gray suede on instagram or shop
gray sweet calm Wow Raven gates we
sipped we spilled we broke yeah we did
it's over thank you everyone bye